OK, here's a couple for you. First him.
好的，给你讲两个人的故事。先讲他。
I usually always say that I'm a Christian first.
我通常总说，我首先是一名基督徒。
Do you still go to church every Sunday?
你现在还会每周日去教堂吗？
Yes, I try to go to church every Sunday. I'm very active in the church. I was the chairman of the congregation.
是的，我尽量每周日都去。我在教会非常活跃。我曾担任过会众主席。
OK, that's him. Now her.
好，那是他。现在讲她。
I'm an atheist. I only go to church on Sunday, let's say, if my daughter is performing a violin recital there. And I don't really participate in the service. I just sit there.
我是个无神论者。我只有在周日才会去教堂，比如说，如果我女儿在那里进行小提琴独奏表演的话。我并不真正参与礼拜。我只是坐在那里。
Can people who have religion and people who don't truly understand each other? Mary and Manford Rauer have been married for 22 years. They have a teenage daughter. It is, surprisingly, harmonious.
有宗教信仰的人和没有宗教信仰的人能真正理解彼此吗？玛丽和曼福德·劳尔已经结婚22年了。他们有一个十几岁的女儿。令人惊讶的是，他们的家庭非常和谐。
And then how would it work when you were president of the congregation? Isn't that the kind of job where, usually, somebody would bring their whole family along to a lot of different kinds of events?
那么，当你担任会众主席时，这怎么行得通呢？那种工作通常不是需要一个人带上全家人参加各种各样的活动吗？
Well, a lot of people thought that he was single, actually. I think people that are not directly involved thought he was single.
嗯，事实上，很多人以为他是单身。我认为那些不直接参与教会的人都以为他是单身。
Yes, that is true. I've been approached, "Oh, my daughter's divorced," or whatever. "Would you like to meet her?" And I said, "I'm sorry. I'm married."
是的，没错。曾有人向我搭讪说：“噢，我女儿离婚了，或者怎样，你想见见她吗？”我说：“对不起，我结婚了。”
Mary was Catholic when they first met and lost her faith by the time they were married. But they talked about these things so infrequently that it wasn't until their daughter was born, years later, that her husband really understood that she wanted no part of religion at all. Here's how they make it work. They have a system, namely, they do not discuss it at all.
他们刚认识时，玛丽还是个天主教徒，但等到结婚时，她已经失去了信仰。但他们极少谈论这些事，直到多年后女儿出生，她丈夫才真正明白她根本不想参与任何宗教活动。这就是他们相处的方式。他们有一套系统，那就是——根本不讨论这个问题。
I'm not going to push the issue because I want a good marriage.
我不会去推行这个问题，因为我想要一段美好的婚姻。
What's there to talk about?
有什么好讨论的呢？
That's why.
就是因为这个。
I mean, if we're going argue every time-- I mean, if I don't believe anything he says, where's the talking? What are we going to talk about? I mean, it doesn't interfere in our everyday life. I mean, maybe he prays for somebody. But he's not one to read the Bible constantly either, so it's not really an issue except Sunday morning, you know?
我的意思是，如果我们每次都要争论——我的意思是，如果我不相信他所说的一切，那还有什么好说的？我们要聊什么呢？我的意思是，这并不影响我们的日常生活。我的意思是，也许他会为某人祈祷。但他也不是那种会不停读圣经的人，所以除了周日上午，这并不是什么问题，你知道吗？
Well, every morning when I get up, I do read the Bible. I guess she doesn't know that.
嗯，每天早上起床时，我都会读圣经。我想她不知道这一点。
You don't know that, do you?
你不知道吧，是吗？
Well, I see him reading the Bible once in a while. It doesn't seem like it's every day, unless he's hiding somewhere and reading it because I certainly don't see it. Where do you read?
嗯，我偶尔看到他在读圣经。看起来不像每天都读，除非他躲在什么地方读，因为我确实没看见。你在哪里读的？
I get up earlier than you do, and I find time to read. I'm in the process of reading the Psalms right now.
我比你起得早，我找到了阅读的时间。我现在正在读《诗篇》。
In a sense this is a more tragic story for him than for her. After all, he believes he's going to heaven. And he believes that when he gets there she will not be there because she doesn't have a relationship with Jesus. And he prays for her and waits for God to intervene in her life. Meanwhile, she does not want him to praying for her. She doesn't want to see the light. And, for all they have together, there's a part of his faith, there's a part of him, that she just doesn't get.
从某种意义上说，这对他的故事比对她更悲剧。毕竟，他相信他会去天堂。他也相信当他到达那里时，她不会在那里，因为她与耶稣没有建立关系。他为她祈祷，等待上帝介入她的生活。与此同时，她不希望他为她祈祷。她不想看到所谓的光明。而且，尽管他们拥有很多共同点，但他信仰中的那一部分，他灵魂的那一部分，却是她无法理解的。
It's not that I don't understand him. It's I understand people wanting their religion and their faith. That's no problem. But the part I have trouble with is why do they believe that? It's like a dream or it's a non-real world. And I'm more in reality here.
并不是我不理解他。我理解人们想要他们的宗教和信仰。那没问题。但我感到困惑的是，为什么他们相信那些？这就像一个梦，或者说一个非现实的世界。而我更立足于现实。
It's not a real world. You mean you feel like they're living in a fantasy.
不是一个真实的世界。你的意思是，你觉得他们生活在幻想中。
Right.
没错。
First of all, I would like to say, because I find that my prayers are answered with my relationship with God when I pray, I think he's in our lives every day. And I feel that God has a direction for your life. And he's going to get you where He needs you to serve him.
首先，我想说，因为我发现当我祈祷时，我的祈祷得到了上帝的回应，通过我与上帝的关系，我认为他每天都在我们的生活中。我觉得上帝对你的生活有指引。他会把你带到他需要你去服侍他的地方。
So, if God has a direction for your life, so I'm directed to be an atheist. That's how I look at this, you know? If God directs your life, he directed me to be an atheist.
所以，如果上帝对你的生活有指引，那么我也被指引成为一名无神论者。我就是这样看待这件事的，你知道吗？如果上帝指引你的生活，那他也指引我成为一名无神论者。
No, God wills everybody to be a Christian.
不，上帝希望每个人都成为基督徒。
Now, do not be deceived by how they're arguing in this little clip of tape. In their normal lives, when they're not being interviewed about the existence of God, these people show all the signs of a couple who are remarkably happy together.
现在，别被他们在这段录音片段中争论的样子所误导。在他们的正常生活中，当他们没有被采访关于上帝是否存在的问题时，这些人展现出了一对夫妻令人羡慕的幸福生活的所有迹象。
Looked at it in one way, this story is about how the secular and religious worlds cannot understand each other, ever. But, looked at in another, it's a story about how well they can, which brings us to today's program. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
换个角度看，这个故事讲述了世俗世界和宗教世界是如何永远无法理解彼此的。但从另一个角度看，它讲述了他们是如何能够和谐共处的，这也引出了今天的节目。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our radio program Christians and non-Christians together again. Act One of our program, Exodus. A completely secular person arrives in a town where thousands of people are taking part in a massive prayer project to save their city. Act Two, Kings. Scott Carrier talks about carpenters and Christians and why the two should not be allowed to be together. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中，基督徒和非基督徒再次聚在一起。我们节目的第一幕，“出埃及记”。一个完全世俗的人来到了一个城镇，成千上万的人正在那里参与一个拯救他们城市的巨大祈祷项目。第二幕，“列王纪”。斯科特·卡里尔讲述了木匠和基督徒的故事，以及为什么这两类人不应该被允许待在一起。请继续收听。
Act One, Exodus. Usually we think of prayer as a private thing. All prayer like all politics is local. Most people pray for those near and dear to them, sort of.
第一幕，“出埃及记”。通常我们认为祈祷是一件私事。所有的祈祷就像所有的政治一样，都是地方性的。大多数人祈祷是为了身边亲近的人，大概是这样。
In Colorado Springs, Colorado, there's an elaborate program underway involving dozens of churches and thousands of people to pray, not just for those nearby, but to try to fundamentally alter the civic life of their city through prayer. The details of how they do this are complicated. It's almost like a modern door-to-door marketing or canvassing campaign. They use maps and computers and statistics to chart out what parts of their city need prayer for what reasons merged with something that cannot be less modern, prayer.
在科罗拉多州的科罗拉多斯普林斯，有一个精细的项目正在进行，涉及几十个教会和成千上万的人，他们祈祷的对象不仅是身边的人，还要试图通过祈祷从根本上改变他们城市的公民生活。他们具体做法的细节很复杂。这几乎就像一种现代的上门营销或拉票活动。他们使用地图、电脑和统计数据来规划城市中哪些部分需要祈祷，原因是什么，并结合了一些绝不现代的东西——祈祷。
And, when This American Life producer, Alix Spiegel, started to investigate it, it became something she could not get out of her mind. She decided she had to go to Colorado to see what it was all about.
而且，当《这个美国生活》的制作人阿利克斯·斯皮格尔开始调查这件事时，这成了她无法从脑海中抹去的东西。她决定必须去科罗拉多看看这到底是怎么回事。
This is the tape that brought me to Colorado Springs. It's a sermon given by Pastor Ted Haggard of the New Life Church about prayer walking. Pastor Ted has taken a map of the city, divided it into districts, assigned those districts to people in his congregation, and together they're walking up and down every street praying for the people in the houses and all the shops and businesses.
这就是把我带到科罗拉多斯普林斯的磁带。这是新生命教会的泰德·哈格德牧师关于祈祷步行的布道。泰德牧师拿了一张城市地图，把它分成不同的区域，把这些区域分配给会众中的成员，他们一起走遍每一条街道，为房子里的人、所有的商店和企业祈祷。
I love grid praying where we walk. You have the parallel streets, and you put a person at the end of each street, and then you walk up and down that street. And at the end of every block you check, make sure your buddy's there, and make sure your buddy's there. Then you do another block, and you make sure your buddy's there, and make sure your buddy's there. Then you pray another block. So you pray over every home, every business, every school, everything. And you realize, you know, if we weren't doing this, some of these people would never be prayed for.
我喜欢网格祈祷，就是我们走路的方式。你有平行的街道，你在每条街道的尽头放一个人，然后你们就在那条街上走来走去。每到一个街区尽头，你就确认一下你的同伴在不在，确认你的同伴在不在。然后你们做下一个街区，再次确认你的同伴在不在。然后再祈祷下一个街区。所以你们为每一个家庭、每一家企业、每一所学校、每一件事祈祷。你会意识到，你知道，如果我们不这样做，这些人中的一些人永远不会得到祈祷。
The thing about this that I find so striking is that it's not a PR campaign. They don't knock on doors. They don't ask for donations. They're not trying to win the hearts and minds of non-Christians by letting them know how much they care about them. In fact, they don't even want the people being prayed for to know that they're being prayed over.
我觉得这一点最引人注目的是，这不是一场公关活动。他们不敲门。他们不寻求捐款。他们不是通过让非基督徒知道他们有多关心他们来赢得非基督徒的心。事实上，他们甚至不希望被祈祷的人知道他们正在被祈祷。
So start walking it discreetly and with wisdom, praying. You don't want to intimidate people. You don't want to embarrass other people or anything like that. Prayer is a private thing. We don't stand up and go, "Come on Holy Spirit," or anything like that. We just walk along, have a baseball cap on, jug of water or whatever, Mountain Dew, if you want some spice. And we'll be walking along and we'll just pray, "Father, in the name of Jesus--
所以开始谨慎而有智慧地行走，祈祷。你不想恐吓别人。你不想让别人感到尴尬之类的。祈祷是一件私事。我们不会站起来说，“圣灵快来”，或者类似的话。我们只是走着，戴着棒球帽，拿着一壶水什么的，或者是激浪汽水，如果你想要点刺激的话。我们会走着然后祈祷，“天父，奉耶稣的名——”
The simplicity of this idea appealed to me, people walking, praying for people they don't know without expectation of reward. I wanted to see if it was as pure an act of kindness as it seemed to be. I wanted to see if all the prayer was having any effect. No other American city is working as systematically to get God's attention. And I thought that, surely, if God is going to speak anywhere in modern America, he's going to speak in Colorado Springs.
这个想法的简单性吸引了我，人们走路，为不认识的人祈祷，而不期望回报。我想看看它是否像看起来那样是一种纯粹的善行。我想看看所有的祈祷是否产生了任何影响。没有其他美国城市像这样系统地引起上帝的注意。我想，如果上帝要在现代美国的任何地方说话，他肯定会在科罗拉多斯普林斯说话。
My first surprise on arriving in Colorado is that the New Life Church looks less like a place of worship and more like a Walgreens than any religious institution I have ever seen. It's a long, flat, gray and turquoise building with a large satellite dish on top where most churches would keep a cross.
我到达科罗拉多后的第一个惊喜是，新生命教会看起来不像一个礼拜场所，而更像一个沃尔格林药店，比我见过的任何宗教机构都更像。它是一座长长的、平坦的、灰色和绿松石色的建筑，上面有一个大卫星天线，而大多数教堂会保留十字架。
New Life is what's known as a megachurch. It has 6,000 members. Over 1% of the population of Colorado Springs, it claims. My second surprise on arriving at New Life is that, while all the people are completely kind, they smile, they're gracious, they always offer to get me coffee even though I don't drink coffee, I can't understand a word they're saying.
新生命教会是所谓的超大型教会。它有6000名成员。它声称占科罗拉多斯普林斯人口的1%以上。我到达新生命后的第二个惊喜是，虽然所有人完全友善，他们微笑，他们亲切，他们总是主动给我咖啡，即使我不喝咖啡，但我听不懂他们在说什么。
As we pray we open a hole in the spiritual dynamics above the earth in the spiritual realm of the earth. So here's planet earth, here.
当我们祈祷时，我们在地球上方的精神领域开启了一个洞。所以，这就是地球。
This is Trish. She works at New Life in the public relations department. She took me to lunch. And, before the food came, I decided to warm her up with a question I thought I knew the answer to. How does prayer work? I figured she'd tell me something like, "You pray. And God hears you. And he answers." But, two napkins worth of diagrams later, I realized it was much more complicated.
这是翠西。她在新生命教会的公关部门工作。她带我吃午饭。在食物送来之前，我决定先用一个我以为知道答案的问题让她进入状态。祈祷是如何起作用的？我以为她会告诉我一些像“你祈祷。上帝听见了。然后他回答你。”之类的话。但是，在看了两餐巾纸的图表后，我意识到这复杂得多。
So what I've done is I just drew an opening in this biosphere of spiritual dynamics that are going on in the heavenlies. And, as we open this sphere, we allow the will of God, the kingdom of God, to come to planet earth.
所以我所做的就是画了一个开口，在天空中正在进行的精神动态生物圈里。当我们打开这个球体时，我们允许上帝的旨意，上帝的国度，来到地球。
Trish, like most of the other Christians I met in Colorado Springs, speaks a very particular language. They're constantly using phrases like spiritual dynamics, standing in the gap, spiritual discernment, intercessors, the Joshua generation, true in your walk, in the natural, the 10/40 window.
翠西像我在科罗拉多斯普林斯遇到的大多数其他基督徒一样，说一种非常特殊的语言。他们不断使用像“精神动态”、“站在缺口处”、“属灵辨别力”、“代祷者”、“约书亚一代”、“真实的行走”、“在自然界中”、“10/40窗口”这样的短语。
And, for me, it's like being in a foreign country. I come from a family of non-religious Jews. I never had any kind of religious training. And, while I know some devout Christians, all of my friends belong to the America that never goes to church on Sunday. After listening to this Christian jargon for a day and a half, I realize that I'm not understanding well enough to do a decent story. So I go and visit the person in charge of setting up my interviews while I'm at New Life, Pastor Joseph Thompson.
对我来说，这就像在一个外国。我来自一个非宗教的犹太家庭。我从未接受过任何形式的宗教训练。虽然我认识一些虔诚的基督徒，但我所有的朋友都属于从不在周日去教堂的美国。听了这些基督徒行话一天半后，我意识到我理解得不够透彻，无法做一个像样的报道。所以我去拜访负责在我待在新生命教会期间安排我采访的人，约瑟夫·汤普森牧师。
Joseph is a tall, broad Nigerian, and I like him. I like him a lot. For a pastor, he's a very worldly man. He was a professional soccer player. He was trained as an architect, speaks several languages, travels widely. And he's the first Christian in Colorado Springs who can tell me a joke.
约瑟夫是一位高大、魁梧的尼日利亚人，我很喜欢他。非常喜欢。作为一名牧师，他是个很世俗的人。他曾是一名职业足球运动员。他受过建筑师培训，会说多种语言，经常旅行。他是科罗拉多斯普林斯第一个能给我讲笑话的基督徒。
We have a refreshingly frank discussion. I tell him that, because of the language thing, I'm afraid that none of the people that I've talked to will be understood by, or appealing to, a secular audience. That I need someone who doesn't sound like they're piping out the party line. Then he tells me that he doesn't believe that what's going on with the Christians in the city of Colorado Springs can be understood by people outside. That, in fact, the whole of the Christian spiritual world is incomprehensible to the secular mind. There is no common ground. I, of course, argue with him, say that people are people, and ultimately we can understand one another. And we go back and forth and back and forth. He insists that the religious can't be understood by the non-religious, I insist they can.
我们进行了一场令人耳目一新的坦诚讨论。我告诉他，因为语言障碍，我担心我采访过的任何人都不会被世俗观众理解或吸引。我需要一个听起来不像是在宣读党派方针的人。然后他告诉我，他不相信科罗拉多斯普林斯市基督徒正在发生的事情能被外面的人理解。事实上，整个基督徒精神世界对世俗思想来说是不可理解的。没有共同点。我当然和他争论，说人就是人，归根结底我们可以互相理解。我们就这样反反复复地辩论。他坚持认为宗教人士无法被非宗教人士理解，我坚持认为他们可以。
And, at some point, I get visibly frustrated and upset. This is when Joseph turns to me with a whole new look in his eyes, like up until this point he didn't understand something that suddenly he understood. And this is what he says. He says, "You're looking for something. You came here for some other reason. You didn't come here to do a story about prayer walking. You were sent here for something else." And I sit, kind of blink at him dumbly, and wonder if he's right.
在某个时刻，我明显感到沮丧和难过。这时，约瑟夫转过身看着我，眼中露出了全新的神色，好像直到这一刻，他才明白了一些他突然理解的事情。他就是这样说的。他说：“你在寻找什么。你来这里是有其他原因的。你不是来做关于祈祷步行的报道的。你是为了别的事情被派到这里的。”我坐在那里，对他笨拙地眨着眼睛，怀疑他是否说对了。
Joseph refers me to a youth group where I finally find a prayer walker who doesn't speak in jargon. His name is Paul. His parents are Mormons, but he became a charismatic Christian two years ago when he joined the New Life Church. That's when he started prayer walking. I go with him early one evening. And he explains that the more specific his prayers are, the more likely it is that God'll answer them. So, as he walks by a house, he looks at the lawn and the stickers on cars searching for physical cues which will tell them what's going on inside.
约瑟夫把我推荐给一个青年团体，在那里我终于找到了一个不说行话的祈祷步行者。他的名字叫保罗。他的父母是摩门教徒，但他两年前加入新生命教会后成为了一名灵恩派基督徒。那时他开始祈祷步行。我一个傍晚和他一起去。他解释说，他的祈祷越具体，上帝回答的可能性就越大。因此，当他走过一所房子时，他看着草坪和汽车上的贴纸，寻找能告诉他里面发生了什么的物理线索。
The outward appearance of the house, you know, the lawn, the way the house is kept up on the outside, you can usually tell. Because they're too busy fighting with their family, that they can't get any of that other stuff done, you know? Like, when my parents got divorced, our lawn looked kind of bad. I really didn't care because I didn't think anything really mattered, you know? I was just like, "Ah, I don't care. Life is dumb."
房子的外表，你知道，草坪，房子外面的维护方式，你通常能看得出来。因为他们忙于和家人吵架，导致他们没法完成其他任何事情，你知道吗？就像我父母离婚时，我们的草坪看起来很糟。我真的不在乎，因为我觉得没什么事真的重要，你知道吗？我当时就像，“啊，我不在乎。生活真蠢。”
If the house looks like it belongs to a couple with kids, Paul will pray for God to keep the kids away from drugs. If the house looks like it belongs to an old person, Paul will pray for God to keep them safe from diseases and pain and bless their grandchildren. It's exactly what I imagined prayer walking would be, people taking time, praying for people they don't know, and asking for nothing in return.
如果房子看起来像是属于一对有孩子的夫妇，保罗会祈祷上帝让孩子远离毒品。如果房子看起来像是属于一个老人，保罗会祈祷上帝保护他们免受疾病和痛苦，并保佑他们的孙辈。这正是我想象中祈祷步行的样子，人们花时间，为他们不认识的人祈祷，不求任何回报。
I watch Paul as he prays. And I can see him really straining to imagine what these people are like. He's standing on the sidewalk in front of his neighbor's blue, two-story house. His eyes are closed. And his eyelids are trembling slightly.
我看着保罗祈祷。我能看到他真的很努力地去想象这些人是什么样的。他站在邻居蓝色两层楼房前的人行道上。他闭着眼睛。眼睑微微颤动。
Thank you so much for this beautiful day, Father. I thank you for the neighbors that you've given me, Father, that they know that there is nothing better than to just sit down and just read your word, or to get on their knees and just pray to you. And, Holy Spirit, I pray you just flow through this house. Go through each and every single room.
非常感谢您赐予这美好的一天，天父。我感谢您赐予我这些邻居，天父，让他们知道没有什么比坐下来读您的圣经，或者跪下来向您祈祷更好的了。而且，圣灵，我祈祷您只流经这所房子。穿过每一个房间。
There's something really intimate about prayer walking, at least, the way it's practiced by Paul. He walks quietly down the street fantasizing about the lives of the people he's praying for, and it changes the way that he feels about them. If he happens to meet them in school or in a neighborhood get-together, he's more friendly than usual and ends up asking a lot of specific personal questions about their family, how everybody's doing.
祈祷步行真的有一种非常亲密的感觉，至少在保罗实践的方式下是这样。他静静地走在街上，幻想他正在祈祷的人的生活，这改变了他对他们的感觉。如果他碰巧在学校或社区聚会中见到他们，他会比平时更友善，最终会问很多关于他们家庭的具体私人问题，每个人怎么样。
I feel as if I've already started some kind of relationship, some kind of friendship, because I prayed for them. And then, once I really start to get to know them more, I will be able to see the fruits of my prayer and see how my prayers have affected that person's life, even if they know it or not.
我觉得好像我已经开始了一种关系，一种友谊，因为我为他们祈祷了。然后，一旦我真正开始更多地了解他们，我将能够看到我祈祷的果实，看到我的祈祷如何影响了那个人的生活，即使他们知道与否。
When I asked Paul how he knows what he's doing is changing anything, he looked at me like I just asked him how he knows the sun will come up tomorrow. And then he asks me a question. God created the earth, why can't he change it?
当我问保罗他怎么知道他所做的一切正在改变任何事情时，他看着我，就好像我刚才问他怎么知道太阳明天会升起一样。然后他问我一个问题。上帝创造了地球，为什么他不能改变它？
The next day, Thursday, I go to visit Joseph in his office just to talk. I find myself going to visit Joseph just to talk quite a bit. I visit or we talk on the phone three, maybe four times, a day. Some of this is logistics. He's helping me find people to interview, giving me telephone numbers. But a lot of it isn't logistics at all.
第二天，周四，我去拜访约瑟夫的办公室只是为了谈谈。我发现自己去拜访约瑟夫只是为了谈谈好多次了。我每天去拜访他，或者我们通电话，三四次。其中一些是后勤问题。他帮我找人采访，给我电话号码。但很多根本不是后勤问题。
We talk about our lives and argue about Christianity. He thinks I'm going to Hell, I don't. He thinks the only way to lead a just life is with Jesus, I don't. And, always, there's this friendly, low-level cultural clash which, for some reason, seems to surprise both of us every time we stumble onto it.
我们谈论我们的生活，争论基督教。他认为我要下地狱，我不这么认为。他认为过正直生活的唯一途径是跟随耶稣，我不这么认为。而且，总是有一种友好的、低水平的文化冲突，出于某种原因，每次我们偶然遇到它时，似乎都会让两人感到惊讶。
At one point he mentions in passing a conference he went to on evolution and tells me about some new evidence they were discussing which proves Darwin was a fool and a fake. I, of course, start to argue. Then there's this long, kind of sad silence. And he says to me, "I should've realized that you would be a Darwinist," which is exactly what I was thinking about him. I should have realized that you would be Creationist.
有一次，他顺便提到了他参加的一个关于进化的会议，告诉了我一些他们正在讨论的新证据，这些证据证明达尔文是个傻瓜和骗子。我当然开始争论。然后是一阵漫长而悲伤的沉默。他对我说，“我应该意识到你会是个达尔文主义者，”这正是我当时对他所想的。我应该意识到你会是个创造论者。
I talk to Joseph about the prayer walkers, tell him about Paul's prayer walk, Paul's empathy for the people he's praying for. Joseph accepts this kind of empathy as a matter of course. "It's the duty of a Christian," he says. At one point, he turns to me.
我和约瑟夫谈到那些祈祷步行者，告诉他保罗的祈祷步行，保罗对他祈祷的人的共情。约瑟夫理所当然地接受了这种共情。“这是基督徒的职责，”他说。有一次，他转向我。
You may not realize this, but there are people praying for you. Even here, now, in this church, people are praying for you so that you will come into a relationship with Jesus the same way that we have experienced.
你可能没意识到这一点，但有人在为你祈祷。即使在这里，现在，在这个教堂里，人们也在为你祈祷，这样你就会像我们所经历的那样，进入与耶稣的关系。
Thursday night I go home to my hotel room and walk in little circles thinking about Joseph. I construct elaborate arguments about why I don't want to become a Christian, why I can't become a Christian. I get one hour of sleep, maybe two.
周四晚上，我回到旅馆房间，绕着小圈走，思考着约瑟夫。我构建了精心论证，说明我为什么不想成为一名基督徒，为什么我不能成为一名基督徒。我睡了一个小时，也许两个小时。
Hi, how you doing?
嗨，你好吗？
Oh, all right.
噢，还可以。
Having a good day?
今天过得愉快吗？
Well, I'll tell you later.
嗯，稍后再告诉你。
OK.
好的。
So far, it's all right.
到目前为止，还可以。
OK, see you.
好的，再见。
The next morning, I have an early appointment with a woman named Jennifer Phillips who's called to pray for the homeless. Twice a week, she goes to the center square in downtown Colorado Springs and prays for all the men and women sleeping on park benches.
第二天早上，我和一位名叫詹妮弗·菲利普斯的女士有个早约，她呼吁为无家可归者祈祷。每周两次，她都会去科罗拉多斯普林斯市中心的中心广场，为所有睡在公园长椅上的男女祈祷。
Jennifer is in her 20s, cute, with a nose pierce and a plaid, button-down, and I like her a lot. But her language is so dense with biblical reference, and I'm so tired, that I just hear this wall of Christianese, spiritual warfare, spiritual strongholds, praying in a spiritual foundation. Then she tells me that she gets nervous when she comes to the park. And it's not just because she's a woman alone, walking at night or in the early morning when there are not many people around. There's another reason she gets nervous.
詹妮弗二十多岁，很可爱，鼻子上带着钉，穿着格子纽扣衬衫，我很喜欢她。但她的语言中充斥着圣经引用，而且我太累了，所以我只听到了一堵基督徒专用的“黑话”之墙，属灵争战、属灵坚固营垒、在属灵基础上祈祷。然后她告诉我，她来到公园时会感到紧张。这不仅仅是因为她是一个独自的女性，在晚上或清晨没人时走动。她感到紧张还有另一个原因。
Demonic strongholds in this area, things that have, just over centuries, that people might have-- I mean, I don't know what this land was years ago. I know there's a lot of land around here where they did sacrifices, cultic things, that you have to pray that out. And, in Ephesians, it talks about being dressed in spiritual armor. It says that Satan roams the earth. He's the prince of the air, and he roams back and forth over the earth.
这个地区的魔鬼坚固营垒，人们几百年来可能——我的意思是，我不知道这片土地多年前是什么样子。我知道这附近有很多土地，他们曾进行祭祀，邪教仪式，你必须为那些祈祷。在《以弗所书》中，它谈到了穿戴属灵军装。它说撒旦在地球上游荡。他是空中掌权者，他在地球上徘徊。
Up until this moment with Jennifer, I thought that prayer walking was about wishing your neighbor well, kind of looking around for the next guy and hoping the best for him. But, as Jennifer talks, I realize that it's something else, something much more medieval. She explains that Satan is a living, active presence, just as God is a living, active presence, and that all around the sunny streets of Colorado Springs there is constant and intensive warfare between the two. Jennifer is one of God's warriors, and it's dangerous.
直到詹妮弗的这一刻，我还以为祈祷步行是关于祝愿你的邻居一切顺利，有点像环顾四周，寻找下一个人，希望他一切都好。但当詹妮弗说话时，我意识到这是别的东西，更中世纪的东西。她解释说撒旦是一个活生生的、活跃的存在，就像上帝是一个活生生的、活跃的存在一样，在科罗拉多斯普林斯阳光明媚的街道周围，两者之间不断进行着剧烈的战争。詹妮弗是上帝的战士之一，这很危险。
I mean, there's times where people go through warfare, spiritual warfare, and we'll pray. And the next week they'll lose their job. There's a woman that intercedes for the church right now, and she lost her job. Strange things just happen to happen that next week after praying. It's a battle, which means you can get hurt too.
我的意思是，有几次人们经历了战争，属灵争战，我们会祈祷。接下来的一周他们就会丢工作。现在有一位为教会代祷的女士，她丢了工作。在祈祷后的那一周，奇怪的事情就这样发生了。这是一场战斗，意味着你也可能受伤。
Have you ever been hurt?
你受过伤吗？
OK, yeah. Like, the next day, Satan will try to accuse you of things. He's the accuser, like through work. You may go through depression or hopelessness.
好吧，是的。就像第二天，撒旦会试图控告你。他是控告者，比如通过工作。你可能会经历抑郁或绝望。
Often, after prayer walking, Jennifer feels isolated, doesn't want to go out and see people or experiences intense self-doubt. These feelings she attributes to Satan. She sees it as his way of punishing her for the good that she does.
通常，祈祷步行后，詹妮弗会感到孤立，不想出门见人，或者经历强烈的自我怀疑。这些感觉她归因于撒旦。她认为这是他惩罚她所做善事的方式。
It is a stunning thing in secular America, where every talk show and magazine article reinforces the idea that there are either situational or chemical explanations for feeling one way or the other, to meet someone who has a completely different way of interpreting her emotional life, someone who believes that the reason that they're depressed today is not because their mother didn't love them or because they don't have enough serotonin juicing up the synapses in their brain, but because a supernatural force put a feeling in their head in order to stop them from doing something good.
在世俗美国，每一个脱口秀和杂志文章都加强了一种想法，即感觉一种方式或另一种方式要么是情境性的，要么是化学性的，遇到一个完全不同方式解读她情绪生活的人，一个认为他们今天抑郁的原因不是因为他们的母亲不爱他们，也不是因为他们大脑突触中没有足够的血清素，而是因为一种超自然力量在他们的脑子里放了一种感觉，为了阻止他们做某件好事，这确实是一件令人震惊的事情。
The way that you just described it, it sounded like you were saying you felt like that was Satan that was putting the depression into you. But do you ever think I feel depressed and there are clear reasons for me to feel depressed? Or do you always see yourself in a spiritual battleground?
你刚才描述的方式，听起来像是你在说你感觉那是撒旦把抑郁放进了你心里。但你有没有想过我感到抑郁是有明确原因的？或者你总是把自己看作是在属灵战场上？
No. No, but there are times that you can tell that all these negative thoughts in your head, and it's like this is not me. This is really bizarre because I'm having an awesome day. No one's hurt me. Life is good. Why am I feeling this way?
不。不，但有时你能看出脑子里所有的负面想法，这感觉就像这不是我。这真的很奇怪，因为我今天过得很棒。没人伤害我。生活很美好。为什么我会这样？
Jennifer tells me that there are prayer walkers who can go around and feel the presence of evil in a place even with their eyes closed. She talks about her experiences coming against witches in Manitoba Springs and the occult in Colorado Springs, about the prayer warriors at New Life who regularly prayer walk certain sections of the city seeking out and destroying the forces of darkness.
詹妮弗告诉我，有些祈祷步行者即使闭着眼睛也能在某个地方感受到邪恶的存在。她谈到她在曼尼托斯普林斯对抗女巫和在科罗拉多斯普林斯对抗邪教的经历，关于新生命教会的祈祷勇士，他们经常在城市的某些地区进行祈祷步行，寻找并摧毁黑暗势力。
In the taped sermons that brought me to Colorado, there had been talk of the occult and of the forces of Satan, but I hadn't really taken it seriously. It seemed more metaphorical. I hadn't realized that they were, literally, on a witch hunt. And, as Jennifer talks, my mind keeps reeling for some common ground.
在我带到科罗拉多的录音布道中，曾提到过邪教和撒旦的力量，但我并没有真正当回事。这似乎更多是隐喻性的。我没有意识到他们实际上是在进行一场猎巫行动。而且，当詹妮弗说话时，我的思绪一直在寻找某种共同点。
What are you thinking?
你在想什么？
What am I thinking? I guess I'm just thinking that I rarely see the world in these terms.
我在想什么？我想我只是在想，我很少以这些术语来看待世界。
Uh-huh. I understand. Yeah, this sounds really bizarre. I know it probably sounds like where is this stuff coming from? What sci-fi novel is this coming from?
嗯哼。我明白。是的，这听起来真的很奇怪。我知道它可能听起来像这些东西是从哪儿来的？这是哪本科幻小说来的？
It does sound a little-- I mean, it doesn't sound-- Yeah. I mean, OK. I'm sure to some people it's going to sound a little sci-fi. I mean, you talk about witches and you talk about covens, and those are things from myths.
听起来确实有一点——我的意思是，听起来不——是的。我的意思是，好吧。我相信对有些人来说这听起来会有点像科幻小说。我的意思是，你谈论女巫，你谈论邪教，而那些是神话里的东西。
After I talk to Jennifer, I call Joseph from a pay phone in town. I tell him that I understand now why he thinks it would be hard to communicate what's happening in Colorado Springs, this vision of the spiritual world, to a secular audience. Joseph doesn't seem surprised by my call. He tells me that he prayed the night before for God to give me insight into the spiritual world, and now God has answered his prayer. Then he asks me pointedly if I slept well. And I tell him that I hadn't really slept at all and that I'm tired and confused. We say goodbye and hang up, but talk again later when I'm back in my hotel room. He says he wants to come clean. He tells me that he didn't just pray for me to receive understanding of the spiritual world, he also prayed to God that I wouldn't sleep, not until I became a Christian.
和詹妮弗谈过之后，我从镇上的公用电话给约瑟夫打电话。我告诉他，我现在明白了为什么他认为向世俗观众传达正在科罗拉多斯普林斯发生的这件事——这种对精神世界的愿景——是很困难的。约瑟夫似乎对我打电话并不感到惊讶。他告诉我，他前一天晚上为我祈祷，求上帝让我对精神世界有所领悟，现在上帝回答了他的祈祷。然后他尖锐地问我睡得好吗。我告诉他我几乎根本没睡，我感到累而且困惑。我们告别挂了电话，但我回到旅馆房间时又和他谈了一次。他说他想坦白。他告诉我，他不仅为我能理解精神世界祈祷，他还向上帝祈祷让我睡不着，直到我成为一名基督徒。
Alix Spiegel's story about prayer in Colorado Springs continues in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔关于科罗拉多斯普林斯祈祷的故事将在来自国际公共广播电台的一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时继续。
This is American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, Christians and non-Christians and how well they can understand each other. We're in the middle of Act One.
这里是《这个美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，基督徒和非基督徒以及他们能在多大程度上理解彼此。我们正处于第一幕的中段。
This is Alix Spiegel's story about dozens of churches in Colorado who've banded together to change the world through prayer. To give you an idea of the extent of the spiritual battle they're waging against the forces of darkness, not only are they systematically praying in front of every home and school and business in Colorado Springs, they're praying through the phone book one name at a time.
这是阿利克斯·斯皮格尔关于科罗拉多几十个教会的故事，他们联合起来通过祈祷改变世界。为了让你了解他们正在对黑暗势力进行的精神斗争的程度，他们不仅系统地在科罗拉多斯普林斯的每一个家庭、学校和企业前祈祷，他们还在翻着电话簿，一个名字一个名字地祈祷。
There are all-night prayer vigils. Churches have organized so that each one takes a different day each month with teams of people praying 24 hours a day. So that, right now, as you hear the sound of my voice, someone, somewhere, is praying for the city of Colorado Springs.
有通宵的祈祷守夜。教会组织起来，每个教会每月轮流一天，团队成员24小时祈祷。所以，现在，当你听到我的声音时，某处，某人，正在为科罗拉多斯普林斯市祈祷。
There's a huge international component to this prayer, flying people to Nepal or Cairo to parts of the world where there aren't a lot of Christians on, what they call, prayer journeys. Groups of people check into hotels, pray for a few days, sometimes never leaving the hotel, then fly back home. They're building a new high-tech world prayer center to coordinate prayer needs in 120 countries. And, while it's possible for secular people to understand the idea of these efforts, is there a gap past which it is impossible for them to understand? Alix Spiegel's story continues.
这种祈祷还有一个巨大的国际组成部分，将人们飞往尼泊尔或开罗等世界上基督徒不多的地方，参加他们所谓的祈祷之旅。一群人入住酒店，祈祷几天，有时从不出酒店，然后飞回家。他们正在建立一个新的高科技世界祈祷中心，以协调120个国家的祈祷需求。而且，虽然世俗的人可能理解这些努力的想法，但是否存在一个他们无法理解的鸿沟？阿利克斯·斯皮格尔的故事继续。
I don't sleep for two days, and it makes me feel like I'm going crazy. I lose my wallet and think about borrowing money from Joseph but decide against it. Several times a day, we talk on the phone, debate Christianity and talk about my story.
我两天没睡，这让我觉得自己快疯了。我丢了钱包，想过向约瑟夫借钱，但决定不这么做。每天几次，我们在电话里交谈，辩论基督教并谈论我的报道。
I alternate between thinking that everybody I'm talking to is insane and thinking, while I'm out on prayer walks or sitting through a church service, that they have something that I don't have. Sometimes, between interviews, I go back to my hotel room and watch TV. I find it comforting. I stare at the glow of the people on television and try to remember what I would think of all this if I were home in Chicago.
我在想我正在与之交谈的每个人都疯了，和在祈祷步行中或坐在教堂礼拜时，认为他们拥有我所没有的东西之间来回摇摆。有时，在采访之间，我回到旅馆房间看电视。我发现这很安慰。我盯着电视上人们的光芒，试图记住如果我在芝加哥的家，我会怎么看待这一切。
I still have a story to do, and so I go and see Ted Haggard, the man who's sermon brought me to Colorado Springs. He tells me that his church looks for evidence, scientifically verifiable evidence, that their prayers are having an effect on the community.
我还有报道要做，所以我去见泰德·哈格德，那个布道把我带到科罗拉多斯普林斯的男人。他告诉我，他的教会寻找证据，科学上可验证的证据，证明他们的祈祷对社区产生了影响。
Yeah, we always see empirical evidence. We started praying in an organized way in 1985. That was 12 years ago. And the crime rate has declined every year for the past 12 years.
是的，我们总是看到经验证据。我们从1985年开始以组织方式祈祷。那是在12年前。犯罪率在过去12年的每一年都在下降。
When I suggest that crime rates are falling all over the country, and that, in most places, this is due mainly to demographics, Ted agreed that there was no positive way to know how much the decrease in crime was due to prayer. But he still thinks it's true.
当我提出全国各地的犯罪率都在下降，而且在大多数地方，这主要是由于人口统计学原因时，泰德同意无法通过正面方式知道犯罪减少有多少是由于祈祷。但他仍然认为这是事实。
Well, I would say that, my response is that, I believe that the scriptures are true. And, because I believe the scriptures are true, God tells us some of the things that prayer will do. So I think it's probably a scientifically verifiable phenomenon.
嗯，我会说，我的回应是，我相信经文是真的。因为我相信经文是真的，上帝告诉了我们一些祈祷会做的事情。所以我认为这可能是一种科学上可验证的现象。
Ted tells me story after story. They pray over vacant lots hoping the land will serve God's purposes, then watch as a church buys the lot. They pray at porno stores.
泰德讲了一个又一个故事。他们为空地祈祷，希望土地能服侍上帝的旨意，然后看着教会买下那块地。他们在色情商店祈祷。
I mean, when we pray around a porno joint on a consistent basis-- we never talk to the people. We don't harass people or anything like that, but we see a dip in their business. We have a team of men that specifically target adult bookstores, and they have hundreds of stories of men pulling in to the adult bookstore and parking, and there they are praying for them.
我的意思是，当我们持续不断地在色情场所周围祈祷时——我们从不和这些人说话。我们不骚扰人什么的，但我们看到了他们的业务下滑。我们有一队人专门针对成人书店，他们有数百个关于男人开车进入成人书店并停车，而他们就在那里为他们祈祷的故事。
You can imagine a group of guys sitting there with their baseball caps and their T-shirts praying, "Father, in the name of Jesus, remind these guys of their mothers. Lord, help them think of any scripture they've ever been exposed to in all their life. Cause them to be in love with their wives." They have hundreds of stories of men getting out of their cars, walking halfway to the door of the adult bookstore and pausing, going back, and getting in their car and driving off.
你可以想象一群戴着棒球帽和T恤的家伙坐在那里祈祷，“天父，奉耶稣的名，提醒这些家伙想起他们的母亲。主啊，帮助他们想起他们一生中接触过的任何经文。让他们爱上他们的妻子。”他们有数百个关于男人下车，走到成人书店门口的一半停下来，回去，上车开走的故事。
Business is good, so I'm sure they're not hitting everybody. You know what I mean?
生意不错，所以我肯定他们没有打中所有人。你明白我的意思吗？
The First Amendment is an adult bookstore and novelty shop about eight miles down the road from New Life on Filmore Avenue. It's one of the places New Life targeted, so I went down there to see how business was going. The store's clerk, Dan, has worked at the First Amendment for four years and hasn't noticed a drop in business.
第一修正案是一家成人书店和精品店，距离新生命教会约八英里，在菲尔莫尔大道上。这是新生命教会瞄准的地方之一，所以我去那里看看生意怎么样。店员丹在第一修正案工作了四年，没注意到生意下滑。
What do you mean? As in anything that's like empirical evidence that this is working? Is that what you're saying?
什么意思？就像任何像这是有效的经验证据那样的东西？你是说这个吗？
I mean, I guess that's part of what I'm saying.
我的意思是，我想这是我所说的部分。
Yeah, because I haven't noticed it, you know? I still get the same amount of people and the sales are still the same, you know? That kind of thing. I've noticed a drop since our sign's been out, you know? So maybe they prayed for my sign to be out. Maybe that's their answer to it. I mean, you know, that may have happened but, other than that, no.
是的，因为我没注意到，你知道吗？我仍然接待同样数量的人，销售额还是老样子，你知道吗？那类事情。自从我们的标志出来后，我确实注意到有下降，你知道吗？所以也许他们为我的标志出来祈祷了。也许那是他们对此的回答。我的意思是，你知道，那可能发生过，但除此之外，没有。
Dan doesn't seem bothered by the idea of people sitting in his parking lot praying for his business to drop off the face of the earth.
丹似乎并没有被人们坐在他的停车场里祈祷他的生意从地球表面消失的想法所困扰。
I mean, they have a right to be there as long as they're not disturbing people. I mean, it would be different if they were holding people up from coming in. But, if all they're doing is praying, then that's very passive-aggressive kind of stuff, you know? It's not like it's a big deal.
我的意思是，他们有权待在那里，只要他们不打扰别人。我的意思是，如果他们阻碍人们进来，那会不一样。但如果他们只是在祈祷，那么那是很被动攻击的东西，你知道吗？这又不是什么大不了的事。
Right. I mean, according to them, they do stop people from--
对。我的意思是，据他们说，他们确实阻止人们——
Physically?
物理上？
Spiritually.
精神上。
Well, spiritually, I mean, you know, they can believe whatever they want. And so they can be out there and it doesn't bother me, and it doesn't offend me. They can judge me. They don't know me. That's OK, I'm used to that. Most religions do judge people without really knowing them.
嗯，精神上，我的意思是，你知道，他们可以相信他们想相信的任何东西。所以他们可以在外面，这不困扰我，也不冒犯我。他们可以审判我。他们不认识我。那没关系，我习惯了。大多数宗教在不真正了解人们的情况下确实会审判他们。
Dan says he prays himself, so he understands the impulse. I asked him if he's noticed any change in the spiritual climate of Colorado Springs what with the prayer shield and the prayer walks, and he tells me no. Most of the changes he's noticed aren't spiritual. The town has gotten bigger, it's more expensive, and people aren't as friendly as they used to be.
丹说他自己也祈祷，所以他理解这种冲动。我问他是否注意到科罗拉多斯普林斯的属灵气候有什么变化，考虑到祈祷盾和祈祷步行，他告诉我没有。他注意到的大多数变化都不是精神上的。城镇变大了，更贵了，人们不像以前那么友好了。
Over on the far side of the store next to the videos I meet a customer, Malcolm.
在商店的远端，在视频旁边，我遇到了一个顾客，马尔科姆。
Prayer warrior, that's what I was before I came out, yes.
祈祷勇士，那是我出来之前做的事情，是的。
It turns out that I don't need to explain much about the spiritual war to Malcolm. The fact is, he would probably do a better job explaining it to me. Malcolm was a full-fledged spiritual warrior until he came out as gay. He was even a member of the New Life Church. Here's a bit of irony. The first time Malcolm ever came to the First Amendment bookstore was on his way home from a singles meeting at New Life. He'd been struggling with being gay and being Christian, and the singles meeting was just the last straw.
事实证明，我不需要对马尔科姆解释太多关于属灵战争的事情。事实是，他可能会比我更好地解释它。马尔科姆曾是一名十足的属灵勇士，直到他出柜为同性恋。他甚至是新生命教会的成员。这里有一点讽刺。马尔科姆第一次来到第一修正案书店是在他从新生命教会的单身会议回家的路上。他一直在与同性恋和基督教的挣扎中苦恼，单身会议只是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。
At this singles meeting, two of my friends embraced in a Christian hug, very Christian hug, and then jumped away from each other and said, "Fag." And that is when I became disheartened, if you will.
在这个单身会议上，我的两个朋友进行了一次基督徒拥抱，非常基督徒的拥抱，然后互相跳开说，“基佬。”就在那时，我灰心了，如果你愿意这么说的话。
So he walked to the First Amendment bookstore and decided to come out. The sad thing about all this is that Malcolm badly misses his life as a Christian. He loved the church and loved being a spiritual warrior. Even now, several years after coming out, Malcolm would probably be happier sitting in the car outside praying than standing in the porn store talking to me.
所以他走到第一修正案书店，决定出柜。关于这一切可悲的事情是，马尔科姆非常怀念他作为基督徒的生活。他爱那个教会，爱做一名属灵勇士。即使现在，出柜几年后，马尔科姆如果坐在外面的车里祈祷，可能会比站在色情店里跟我说话更快乐。
I guess I have to admit I like the Christian environment more. There seems to be more spiritual love going on than this environment where there's only physical love.
我想我必须承认我更喜欢基督徒的环境。似乎有更多的属灵爱在发生，而不是这个只有身体爱的环境。
So you basically agree with them that this is demonic?
所以你基本上同意他们的看法，这很邪恶？
Yes, [LAUGHS] paradox.
是的，[笑] 悖论。
Yeah, it is a paradox. That must be--
是的，这是一个悖论。那一定——
I am really torn, yes, between what I was brought up with and what I'm doing now.
我真的很纠结，是的，在我和我从小被教育的东西以及我现在所做的事情之间。
Do you ever have a fantasy that they would be able to pray enough to change you? I mean, was that a fancy that you used to have?
你有没有幻想过他们能够祈祷足够多来改变你？我的意思是，那是不是你过去常有的幻想？
Yea, and, if by some chance I do wake up one morning and I'm no longer gay, I will believe that there were Christians intervening.
是的，如果万一我某天早上醒来，我不再是同性恋，我会相信有基督徒在介入。
At the end of the interview I ask him if I've left anything out, do you want to say anything else?
采访结束时，我问他我是否漏掉了什么，你想再说点什么吗？
To you, personally, and to anyone else, I would not turn Jesus away just because of what the Christians do. Jesus isn't the bad guy.
对你个人，以及对任何其他人，我不会因为基督徒做什么而拒绝耶稣。耶稣不是坏人。
Can I just point out that you're sitting in the middle of a porno store, and you're trying to save me?
我能指出你正坐在色情商店中间，而你正在试图拯救我吗？
Yeah, that's crazy. I know.
是的，那很疯狂。我知道。
Joseph calls me early in the morning, around 6 o'clock, to check in and see how I'm doing. Thanks to the power of prayer, I am, of course, awake. We talk for a while. I tell him about the guy in the porno store, how tragic he seemed. We argue about homosexuality, and the argument runs pretty much as you would expect. I'm for the homos. Joseph thinks that they can't be gay and saved at the same time.
约瑟夫在清晨六点左右打电话给我，检查并看看我过得怎么样。多亏了祈祷的力量，我当然醒了。我们谈了一会儿。我告诉他关于色情店里的那个人，他看起来多么悲剧。我们争论同性恋，争论进行得就像你预期的那样。我支持同性恋。约瑟夫认为他们不能同时是同性恋又同时得救。
When I tell him that I could never be part of a religion that doesn't accept homosexuals, he's shocked, really shocked and disappointed by my tolerance. But Joseph doesn't give up on me. He tells me that, one day, when I'm a Christian and we're best friends, we'll look back on all of this and laugh. And there's something about the way that he says this that makes me feel deep inside that, yes, of course, he's right. One day, went I'm a Christian and we're best friends, we will look back on all of this and laugh. I don't tell Joseph that I think this.
当我告诉他我永远不可能成为一个不接受同性恋者的宗教的一部分时，他很震惊，真的对我的宽容感到震惊和失望。但约瑟夫并没有放弃我。他告诉我，有一天，当我成为一名基督徒，我们成为最好的朋友时，我们会回顾这一切并大笑。他说这话的方式让我内心深处感觉到，是的，当然，他是对的。有一天，当我成为一名基督徒，我们成为最好的朋友时，我们会回顾这一切并大笑。我没有告诉约瑟夫我这么想。
After we hang up, I don't know what to do, so I call my boss, Ira, in Chicago. It's 7:30 Chicago time on a Sunday morning, and I wake him up. I want him to put this experience in perspective for me, tell me that he's been through the same thing. He tries, in various ways to be reassuring and finally tells me that he believes that, ultimately, my life is with the secular world and the show in Chicago. One day, he says, when I'm back in Chicago hard at work at my digital editing station, we'll look back on all of this and laugh. Ira is much less convincing than Joseph.
挂断电话后，我不知道该做什么，所以我给芝加哥的老板艾拉打了电话。那是周日上午芝加哥时间7点半，我把他吵醒了。我希望他能为我把这种经历放在一个视角中，告诉我他也经历过同样的事情。他试图以各种方式让我安心，最终告诉我他相信，最终，我的生活属于世俗世界和芝加哥的节目。他说，有一天，当我回到芝加哥在我的数字编辑站努力工作时，我们会回顾这一切并大笑。艾拉比约瑟夫说得少得多。
We kind of go into Satan's turf. Some people enjoy that more than others. Some people really like to spend more time praying in lighter areas and not so spiritually dangerous areas.
我们有点进入了撒旦的领域。有些人比其他人更喜欢那个。有些人真的喜欢花更多时间在较亮的地方祈祷，而不是精神上危险的地方。
And how about you?
那你呢？
Well, I like the dark stuff. I'm called to walk in dark places.
嗯，我喜欢黑暗的东西。我被呼召去黑暗的地方行走。
My attraction to becoming a Christian suffers a setback when I go out with a prayer walker named Jared, who does hard-core spiritual warfare. He not only wanders around blessing his neighbors but actively tries to fight demons.
当我和一位名叫杰瑞德的祈祷步行者出去时，我对成为基督徒的吸引力受到了挫折，他进行硬核属灵争战。他不仅四处走动祝福邻居，还积极试图与恶魔战斗。
Jared's a Harvard grad in his late 20s. And I'm told by several people that his prayer walks are intense, lots of frenzied spiritual confrontation. Jared seems proud of this and, as we walk, he explains that sophisticated prayer walkers don't need to rely on physical cues to know if the forces of Satan are present.
杰瑞德是哈佛毕业生，二十多岁。几个人告诉我他的祈祷步行很强烈，有很多疯狂的精神对抗。杰瑞德似乎为此感到自豪，当我们走着时，他解释说，老练的祈祷步行者不需要依赖物理线索就知道撒旦的力量是否存在。
The interesting thing is that, if you blindfolded Jen or I or someone who had developed their gifts of discernment, and took us to a place, and we couldn't see what was going on, and even if I couldn't hear what was going on, spiritually, I could receive discernment on the place.
有趣的是，如果你蒙上我和詹妮弗或某个发展了辨别天赋的人的眼睛，把我们带到一个地方，我们看不到发生了什么，甚至如果我听不到发生了什么，在精神上，我可以获得对这个地方的辨别。
Jared, Jennifer Phillips, their friend, Sarah and I go to confront the forces of darkness on a particularly peaceful summer afternoon. And it's hard, at least for me, to sense the presence of anything sinister. We walk in a park past some skateboarders down a couple blocks to a school. And then, as we walk around the back of the school, Jennifer, Sarah, and Jared come up short.
杰瑞德、詹妮弗·菲利普斯、他们的朋友莎拉和我去一个特别宁静的夏日下午对抗黑暗势力。至少对我来说，很难感知到任何险恶的东西。我们走过一个公园，经过一些滑板手，走过几个街区到一所学校。然后，当我们绕到学校后面时，詹妮弗、莎拉和杰瑞德停了下来。
I wonder-- something's here.
我不知道——这里有东西。
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑]
Like-- Like--
像——像——
Tell us.
告诉我们。
So, just in walking into this area, it's different.
所以，走在这个区域，感觉不同。
We're in the back of the school standing under a high brick archway in the middle of the school's courtyard. There are benches placed to form a circle. And, for a moment, I stand there wondering what this place witnessed. A gang rape? A murder? Sarah pipes up. She says she went to this school. She knows what happened in the court yard.
我们在学校后面，站在学校庭院中间的高砖拱门下。长椅摆放成一个圆圈。有一瞬间，我站在那里想这个地方见证了什么。轮奸？谋杀？莎拉插嘴。她说她上过这所学校。她知道庭院里发生了什么。
It's where all the drama people used to hang out during lunchtime.
那是午餐时间戏剧社的人常待的地方。
"They're liberals," Jennifer says. Then she and Sarah get self-conscious, like they're afraid they've offended me seeing as I'm a member of the media and a Jew.
“他们是自由派，”詹妮弗说。然后她和莎拉变得有些不自在，好像她们担心冒犯了我，因为我是媒体的一员，还是个犹太人。
Not so much liberal. I don't want to say that.
不仅仅是自由派。我不想这么说。
Well, what is the word then? It's almost like-- well?
嗯，那词是什么？它几乎就像——嗯？
Accepting of ideas?
接受思想？
Yes.
是的。
More open to different interpretations of things. It sounds like people that come to this place are more open to other religions, different views of morality, a bunch of different things, more likely to try things. And, because that they're more likely to try things, people, generally in drama or the arts, are more open to different ideas. Often those people not only are they more open to try things but they actually do try things.
更开放地对待事物的不同解读。听起来来到这个地方的人更开放地对待其他宗教、道德观的不同看法、一堆不同的事物，更有可能尝试事情。而且，因为他们更有可能尝试事情，通常在戏剧或艺术界的人更开放地对待不同的思想。这些人不仅更开放地尝试事物，而且他们确实尝试了。
They move to the center of the circle, close their eyes, and pray.
他们移动到圆圈中心，闭上眼睛，祈祷。
Dear Lord God, we come to you, Lord God, realizing, Lord God, that there's something different about this place, Lord God. That, in the spirit realm, Lord God, there's a darkness over this place, Lord God. Lord, we come to you, Lord God, and we bind any deceiving spirits, Lord God, that may be in operation here, Lord God.
亲爱的主上帝，我们来到您面前，主上帝，意识到，主上帝，这个地方有什么不同，主上帝。在精神领域，主上帝，这个地方上方有黑暗，主上帝。主啊，我们来到您面前，主上帝，我们捆绑任何欺骗的灵，主上帝，可能在这里运作，主上帝。
Any demonic powers or forces, Lord God, that lead people away from truth, Lord God, if they lead them into false religions, Lord God, or ways of looking at morality, Lord God, that are not consistent with your word or anything, Lord God, we ask, Lord God, that you would bind those powers, Lord God, that you would bind them, Lord God, with chains of iron, Lord God.
任何魔鬼力量或势力，主上帝，引导人们远离真理，主上帝，如果他们引导人们进入伪宗教，主上帝，或道德观，主上帝，与您的道或任何东西不一致，主上帝，我们求您，主上帝，您会捆绑那些力量，主上帝，您会捆绑他们，主上帝，用铁链，主上帝。
The next time I talk to Joseph on the phone I tell him about my prayer walk with Jared. I say that I know it'll sound ridiculous to a secular audience, but I have to use it anyway. He doesn't seem to care. Joseph never expected to be understood in the media. He's much more concerned with me and my salvation. And it's hard not to find that touching. He invites me to come and hear him pastor. He's speaking at the Solid Rock Christian Church. Solid Rock is a poor black church in a strip mall in Southern Colorado Springs, just two rooms in a space that looks like it might once have been a large Kinko's or a Mail Boxes Etc.
下次我在电话里和约瑟夫谈话时，我告诉了他我和杰瑞德的祈祷步行。我说我知道这对世俗观众来说听起来很荒谬，但我必须无论如何使用它。他似乎不在乎。约瑟夫从没指望在媒体中被理解。他更关心我和我的救赎。而很难不觉得那很感人。他邀请我去听他做牧师。他在坚石基督教教堂演讲。坚石教堂是科罗拉多斯普林斯南部商场里的一个贫穷的黑人教堂，空间里只有两个房间，看起来可能曾经是一个大的金考快印或Mail Boxes Etc。
The group prays together, then Joseph begins his sermon. It's about reaching out to the lost. He asks how many people in the church have more than one or two non-Christian friends. And, in a room of about 35 adults, maybe five tentatively raise their hands. Then he tells them that he does not even have a single non-Christian friend. "This is wrong," he says. "It's not enough to live justly within the four walls of the church. Christians must find a way to make themselves understandable to non-Christians."
小组一起祈祷，然后约瑟夫开始他的布道。这是关于接触迷途的人。他问教堂里有多少人拥有不止一两个非基督徒朋友。在大约35名成年人的房间里，也许五个人试探性地举起了手。然后他告诉他们，他甚至没有一个非基督徒朋友。“这是错的，”他说。“在教堂四堵墙内过正直的生活是不够的。基督徒必须找到一种方法让自己被非基督徒理解。”
He says this issue has come up a number of times in the past couple of days. And, as he says this, he stands in front of me. He says my name and introduces me. And then he starts to talk about the conversations we've been having. He talks about our conversations and then talks about something else. And then talks in a general way about our conversations and then talks about something else. And, at one point, after saying that Christians need to help those in need, he comes and stands in front of me and says, "I love you, Alix." And the nice woman sitting beside me puts her arm over my shoulder, smiles, and passes me a Kleenex.
他说这个问题在过去几天里提起了好几次。而且，当他说这话时，他站在我面前。他说了我的名字并介绍了我。然后他开始谈论我们一直在进行的对话。他谈到我们的谈话，然后谈论别的事情。然后以一般方式谈论我们的谈话，然后谈论别的事情。而且，在某一点，在说基督徒需要帮助那些有需要的人之后，他过来站在我面前说，“我爱你，阿利克斯。”坐在我旁边的友善女士把胳膊搭在我的肩膀上，微笑着，递给我一张纸巾。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
At the end of his sermon, the group begins to sing. No band, just people singing without accompaniment. And Joseph comes over and asks if he can pray with me. At first, I shake my head no. I'm not sure why, but the thought literally terrifies me. But he asks again, and I can't think of a rational reason not to do it. After all, he's only asking me to pray.
布道结束时，小组开始歌唱。没有乐队，只是人们在没有伴奏的情况下歌唱。约瑟夫过来问他是否可以和我一起祈祷。起初，我摇头表示不。我不确定为什么，但那个想法字面上让我感到恐惧。但他又问了一次，我想不出不这么做的理性原因。毕竟，他只是要求我和他一起祈祷。
So I put down my tape player. And he takes my hands in his, and bows his head, and begins to pray. And, if you paid me money, I couldn't tell you a word he said. I remember the acute sense that I was in a strip mall church in the city, 1,000 miles away from my home, and that the man standing in front of me badly wanted me to become a Christian, was offering me love and comfort if I would only say yes.
所以我放下录音机。他把我的手握在他手中，低下头，开始祈祷。而且，如果你付钱给我，我也说不出他说了什么。我记得那种强烈的感受，我是在城市里一个商场里的教堂，距离我的家1000英里远，站在我面前的人非常渴望我成为一名基督徒，如果我只是说愿意，他正向我提供爱和安慰。
It seemed clear that the people around me were already experiencing the relief that was being extended to me, and that, if I were to act rationally, I would just cross over and join them. But, somehow, I couldn't act rationally. I couldn't become a Christian. Most of all, I remember the sheer effort of trying to keep my composure.
很明显，我周围的人已经体验到了正扩展给我的宽慰，如果我理性行动，我会跨越过去加入他们。但是，不知何故，我无法理性行动。我无法成为一名基督徒。最重要的是，我记得试图保持冷静的纯粹努力。
When we had finished, I sat down and watched as Joseph approached a woman in the third row. She was singing. And he laid his hands on her shoulders, gently, right next to her neck. And, all of a sudden, she just started screaming long, wailing screams.
当我们结束后，我坐下来看着约瑟夫走近第三排的一位女士。她正在唱歌。他温柔地把手放在她的肩膀上，就在她的脖子旁边。然后，突然间，她开始尖叫，长长的、哀号的尖叫。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
[INTERMITTANT SCREAMS]
[间歇性的尖叫]
I felt like I understood why she was screaming. And I don't know if it's God, and I don't know if it's not, but I don't think it matters.
我觉得我理解她为什么尖叫。我不知道那是否是上帝，我不知道那是否不是，但我不认为那有关系。
Alix Spiegel here in Chicago.
在芝加哥的阿利克斯·斯皮格尔。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "BUSLOAD OF FAITH" BY LOU REED]
[音乐播放 - 卢·里德的“信念之车”]
Act Two, Kings. I am damned. I am going to Hell. This is what my fundamentalist friends tell me. They say, no matter what I do in this life, no matter what good works or virtue I ever concoct for myself, I am condemned because I, I and my entire race, the Jews, have not accepted Jesus. But, in these moments before I and maybe you burn forever, let's hear this next story. It is from Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City about the damned and the saved.
第二幕，“列王纪”。我被诅咒了。我要下地狱。这就是我的原教旨主义朋友告诉我的。他们说，无论我在这辈子做什么，无论我为自己炮制什么善行或美德，我都受到谴责，因为我，我和我的整个种族，犹太人，没有接受耶稣。但是，在我和也许你永远燃烧之前的这些时刻，让我们听听下一个故事。它来自盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔，关于被诅咒者和被拯救者。
At a particularly low point in my career as a responsible husband and father I worked as a carpenter's assistant for my younger brother, a contractor specializing in home renovation. We built additions and garages, finished basements, tore out bathrooms and installed new ones. He paid me $10 an hour, which I consider to be generous. At that time, good carpenters, men who could build an entire house from start to finish, single-handed, were making $12.50. And I was only an assistant, a gopher, the guy who digs and carries and cleans up.
在我作为负责任丈夫和父亲的职业生涯中一个特别低落的时刻，我为我年轻的弟弟工作，他是一名承包商，专门从事家庭装修。我们盖加建房和车库，完成地下室，拆掉浴室安装新浴室。他每小时付给我10美元，我觉得这很慷慨。当时，好木匠，那些能从头到尾单枪匹马盖整座房子的人，赚12.55美元。而我只是个助手，个跑腿的，挖掘、搬运、打扫的人。
My brother was maybe 32 at that time and had worked as a carpenter since he'd graduated from college. He'd been a good student and was offered a graduate fellowship. But he dropped it, and no one in my family really understood why. He went to work for other people and, eventually, got his own license and enough equipment to start getting his own contracts. He had a lot of work, usually two jobs going at once and three or four employees, but he wasn't making much money because he had a tendency to underestimate the bids. I think, sometimes, I ended up making more money on a job than he did, but he seemed to like it anyway.
我弟弟当时大概32岁，自从大学毕业以来一直做木匠。他是个好学生，曾被提供研究生奖学金。但他放弃了，我家没人真正明白为什么。他为别人工作，最终，拿到了自己的执照和足够的设备开始拿到自己的合同。他有很多工作，通常同时进行两个工作，有三四个员工，但他没赚到什么钱，因为他有低估投标的倾向。我想，有时我最终赚的钱比他多，但他似乎仍然喜欢那样。
I, however, was almost always upset, not because the work was hard but because I just resented working on another man's house, a man with enough money to pay for a $40,000 bathroom, a man who decides he wants a bigger garage for his new motorcycle, a man who doesn't want to dig up his on sewer pipe. The work forced me to admit that I was a slave, that somewhere in life I'd made a big mistake.
然而，我几乎总是心烦意乱，不是因为工作辛苦，而是因为我就是讨厌在另一个男人的房子工作，一个有钱支付4万美元浴室的男人，一个决定想要为他的新摩托车要一个更大车库的男人，一个不想挖他自己下水道管子的男人。工作迫使我承认我是一名奴隶，在生活的某个地方我犯了一个大错误。
Also, I had a problem with the other carpenters my brother hired. Consider the following scenarios. I'm shingling a garage roof with a lead carpenter named Dave. It's Dave's first day on the job and we're both up there pounding shingles and talking about Star Trek. Dave's a big Star Trek fan. He's seen all of the old and new shows, and even has floor plans of the Enterprise, which he's committed to memory.
此外，我对弟弟雇佣的其他木匠有问题。考虑以下场景。我正和一位名叫戴夫的领班木匠一起给车库屋顶铺瓦。那是戴夫工作的第一天，我们都在上面捶瓦片，谈论《星际迷航》。戴夫是个大《星际迷航》迷。他看过所有的旧节目和新节目，甚至有已经背诵下来的“企业号”的平面图。
Dave tells me about the insidious Borg, a race of cyborgs with a social conscience of ants. Dave knows why the Klingons are now part of the Federation. And Dave has decided just how he would spend his time on the holodeck, a room on the Enterprise where crew members go to live out their fantasies in holographic reality.
戴夫向我讲述了阴险的博格人，一个有着蚂蚁社会良知的改造人种族。戴夫知道为什么克林贡人现在是联邦的一部分。戴夫已经决定了他会如何度过他在全息甲板上的时间，那是“企业号”上一个成员去在全息现实中实现他们幻想的房间。
It's a harmless conversation that seems to diminish the tedium of the work. But then, after a brief lull, Dave stops pounding shingles and asks me in a very serious tone, "Scott, have you accepted Christ as your personal savior?" It turns out Dave is a fundamentalist Christian with a strong desire to proselytize.
这是一种无害的谈话，似乎减少了工作的乏味。但随后，在短暂的平静后，戴夫停止捶瓦片，用非常严肃的语调问我，“斯科特，你接受基督作为你的个人救主了吗？”原来戴夫是一个有着强烈传教欲望的原教旨主义基督徒。
That evening, after work, I ask my brother if, maybe, he doesn't need a foundation dug or some fiberglass insulation stapled into place, anything other than working with Dave. He looks at the ground, and kicks the dirt, and says he promised the owner that the roof would be done last week.
那天晚上，下班后，我问我弟弟，他也许不需要挖地基或铺设玻璃纤维隔热层，除了和戴夫一起工作之外的任何事情。他看着地面，踢着泥土，说他答应了屋主屋顶上周就会完成。
After Dave, there's Steve, who tells me about how, in Idaho, they're implanting silicon chips in baby's ankles that will forever identify them as part of Satan's army. After Steve, there's another Dave, who, when he's alone, practices out loud shouting his sermons exposing the evils of the Trilateralist Commission.
在戴夫之后，是史蒂夫，他告诉我关于在爱达荷州，他们正在给婴儿脚踝植入硅芯片，那将永远识别他们是撒旦军队的一部分。在史蒂夫之后，是另一个戴夫，当他一个人时，会大声练习喊他的布道，揭露三边委员会的邪恶。
And, after that Dave, there's John, who my brother hires as a grant to help me out. John's just arrived from Boston where he drove a cab for 20 years up until the Kennedys ran him out of town. He says Ted Kennedy was out to get him. He says Ted Kennedy has ruined his life. And he tells me the amazing story of how, while hitchhiking west through Kansas, he became so depressed he decided to throw himself in front of a semi truck barreling down I-70. But then, suddenly, from out of nowhere, he saw Jesus Christ standing 40 feet tall on the side of the road. Jesus spoke to him. He said, "John, these trucks are my roller skates."
在那之后，是约翰，我弟弟雇他来帮我。约翰刚从波士顿到达，他在那里开了20年出租车，直到肯尼迪一家把他赶出城。他说泰德·肯尼迪想对付他。他说泰德·肯尼迪毁了他的生活。他告诉我一个惊人的故事，关于当他沿堪萨斯州向西搭便车时，他变得如此沮丧，以至于他决定跳到一辆在70号州际公路上飞驰的半挂卡车前。但突然，从虚无中，他看到耶稣基督站在路边40英尺高。耶稣对他说话。他说，“约翰，这些卡车是我的溜冰鞋。”
You know, when you see a thing happen once, it's an accident. When you see it happen twice, it's a coincidence. And, when you see it happen three or more times, it's a science, and sciences demand theories.
你知道，当你看到一件事发生一次，那是一个意外。当你看到它发生两次，那是一个巧合。当你看到它发生三次或更多，那是一门科学，科学需要理论。
My first theory was that there might be some sort of connection between Jesus and these men because they were all carpenters. And so I would ask my workmates questions like, "Was Jesus a framer or a finish man? I mean, it makes a difference, don't you think" "Was he the lead carpenter or was he just a laborer?" Or I'd make stuff up like, "I heard that when Jesus built furniture he never used glue in the joints, that he'd just touch them and they'd hold forever."
我的第一个理论是，耶稣和这些人之间可能有什么联系，因为他们都是木匠。所以我问我的同事像这样的问题，“耶稣是个框架工还是精加工工？我的意思是，这有区别，你不觉得吗？”“他是领班木匠还是他只是个劳工？”或者我会编造一些东西像，“我听说当耶稣做家具时他从不用胶水连接，他只是摸一下它们它们就会永远固定。”
But these men were not interested in philosophy or metaphysics. And they were not even interested, it turned out, in stories about Jesus or his teachings of compassion. Far from it. They were all into the book of Revelations. They were all religious for reasons of revenge. All had had hard lives filled with injustices and inequities. All had resigned themselves to a life over which they'd lost control. Their one hope was that, when they die, when everybody dies, everybody will get what they deserve. The righteous will be happy forever while the bastards, the assholes, the wicked and corrupt and the filth will burn in Hell.
但这些男人对哲学或形而上学不感兴趣。而且事实证明，他们甚至对关于耶稣或他慈悲教义的故事也不感兴趣。远非如此。他们全都沉迷于《启示录》。他们全都为了复仇的原因而宗教化。所有人都过着充满不公和不平等的艰苦生活。所有人都认命于一个他们失去了控制的生活。他们唯一的希望是，当他们死去时，当所有人死去时，每个人都会得到他们应得的。正义的人将永远快乐，而混蛋、混蛋、邪恶和腐败以及肮脏的人将在地狱中燃烧。
So I changed my theory and decided that religion is something people use, not only because they want to connect with a sense of their spiritual existence, they also use it to bring a sense of justice to their social existence. Just wait until Jesus comes back. Just wait until the apocalypse. I thought, at first, that I was different, even superior to these guys. But, at some point, I started to realize that we all had the same basic problem. We were all slaves, unhappy slaves, and it wasn't a pretty thing to see.
所以我改变了我的理论，决定宗教是人们使用的东西，不仅因为他们想要联系他们精神存在的意义，他们还使用它来给他们的社会存在带来一种正义感。等着瞧耶稣回来吧。等着瞧末日吧。起初我觉得我和这些人不同，甚至比他们优越。但，在某一点，我开始意识到我们都有同样的基本问题。我们都是奴隶，不快乐的奴隶，看到那景象并不美丽。
I went on like this for more than a year, angry and depressed and unable or unwilling to do anything else. And then, one day in the middle of winter, everything came to a head and sort of exploded. We were building a three-story addition onto the back of an architect's home. He'd designed it. And we'd framed the thing.
我这样持续了一年多，愤怒和沮丧，无法或不愿做任何别的事情。然后，冬天的某一天，所有东西都爆发了。我们正在为一位建筑师家的后面加盖一个三层楼的扩建。他设计的。我们搭好了框架。
And we're starting to sheet the roof when a building inspector came by and said we'd screwed up, made a mistake down at the level of the foundation. It was a small thing, a trivial thing. And I can't even remember now, specifically, what the problem was. And then, it wasn't like we'd done anything wrong. We'd built it like it was drawn in the plans. And the architect was happy with our work, but it just didn't quite match the city's building code. And the inspector was being a hard-ass. He said we'd have to fix it, which meant, in effect, we'd have to tear the whole thing down and start over.
我们正开始在屋顶上铺板时，一名建筑检查员经过说我们搞砸了，在地基水平犯了个错误。那是件小事，一件琐事。我现在甚至不记得具体问题是什么了。而且这不像我们做错了什么。我们是按照图纸画的那样盖的。建筑师对我们的工作很满意，但这并不完全符合城市的建筑规范。检查员是个混蛋。他说我们得修复它，这意味着，实际上，我们得把整个东西拆掉重新开始。
I was standing there in the mud with my brother and the inspector. And it was snowing, and I was wet and cold. And I couldn't believe what I was hearing. My brother just listened and didn't argue or protest. And the inspector showed no sign of regret or remorse. He filled out a form, signed it, gave it to my brother and left.
我站在泥泞中，和我弟弟以及检查员一起。正在下雪，我又湿又冷。我无法相信我听到的。我弟弟只是听着，没有争论或抗议。检查员没表现出后悔或懊悔。他填了一张表格，签了字，给了我弟弟，然后离开了。
I was furious. I took off my belt and threw it across the yard, nails and screws and tools scattering and disappearing in the snow. John stopped work and then came over. And I told him we were going to have to take everything down. And he started in about the Kennedys, how he knew a lawyer in Boston, how we could sue the inspector for everything he was worth. I told him to shut the [BLEEP] up and asked my brother what we're going to do.
我气疯了。我解下我的腰带，把它扔过院子，钉子、螺丝和工具散落并在雪中消失。约翰停止工作走过来。我告诉他我们得把所有东西拆掉。他开始说起肯尼迪一家，他怎么认识波士顿的一位律师，我们怎么能起诉检查员。我告诉他闭嘴，问我弟弟我们要怎么办。
He was standing inside, on the bottom floor, looking out through an empty window. And he said, "Mark your time cards for a full day, and let's clean up and go home early." If he was mad, I couldn't see it. If he was at the point of tears, I couldn't feel it. We put everything away. And, just as I was leaving, he said, "Thanks. It'll be all right. I'll go down to the City Hall tomorrow and talk to some people."
他正站在里面，底层，透过一个空窗户看出去。他说，“把你们的时间卡标记为完整的一天，让我们打扫干净早点回家。”如果他生气，我看不出来。如果他快哭了，我感觉不到。我们把所有东西放好。就在我要离开时，他说，“谢谢。会好起来的。明天我会去市政厅和一些人谈谈。”
I got in my car and loaded my pipe and smoked a bowl and drove away. It was still snowing and cars were sliding into the gutters and getting stuck. And I was trying to figure out why I was so pissed when my brother seemed unfazed. After all, he'd have to pay us to do the extra work, money that would come out of his pocket, not ours. Then I realized that it was his life, that he'd chosen to do this and he didn't hate it. He didn't hate anything about it.
我上了车，装好烟斗抽了一碗，然后开车走了。雪还在下，汽车滑进沟里被卡住了。我试图弄明白为什么我如此愤怒而我弟弟看起来没受到影响。毕竟，他得付钱让我们做额外的工作，钱会从他的口袋里出，而不是我们的。然后我意识到那是他的生活，他选择做这件事而且他不讨厌它。他不讨厌关于它的任何事情。
He was my younger brother. And I'd never really gotten along with him all that well because I have an older brother whom I've always looked up to and loved without question or reason ever since I can remember. My little brother was, in my opinion, an intrusion, an unwanted and unneeded addition to the family. When I was two and my mother brought him home from the hospital, I threw a bar of soap at him. The next day, I threw a garbage can at him, and it never got much better.
他是我弟弟。我从没真正和他相处得那么好，因为我有位我一直仰慕和无缘无故地爱的哥哥。我弟弟在我看来是一个入侵者，一个不受欢迎和不需要的家庭添加物。我两岁时母亲把他从医院带回家，我向他扔了一块肥皂。第二天，我向他扔了一个垃圾桶，情况从未好转多少。
But then he hired me when I needed a job. And, like I said, he paid me more than I was worth, and he treated me with respect even though he could have rubbed it in. And now I was learning something from him. He never went to church. I never once heard him speak about God, but he had more grace and compassion than all of the Christians he'd hired put together.
但后来我需要工作时他雇了我。而且，就像我说的，他付给我的钱比我值得的多，即使他本可以讽刺我，但他对我表示了尊重。现在我正在向他学习东西。他从不去教堂。我一次也没听过他谈论上帝，但他拥有的恩典和怜悯比他雇佣的所有基督徒加起来都多。
Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City.
盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德协助。《这个美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助资金致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who knows how public radio could really raise some money.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他知道公共广播如何真正筹集到一些资金。
We have a team of men that specifically target adult bookstores.
我们有一队人专门针对成人书店。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《这个美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。